est ce que il ya certaines banques les
plus fragiles peuvent faire faillite
s'il vous plaît en france très
clairement non
vous êtes sûrs même les plus sûres on
peut en parler même dans 10 ans je
tiendrai le même discours sur les
sociétés solides et par exemple si on
dit dans une banque n'est pas violent
l'âme il est le seul ancien barclays que
oui entre anglet il faut faire attention
non pas particulièrement les banques
européennes à l'exception des banques
italiennes ce qu'il ya des jeux lire des
français qui sont dans des banques aussi
acceptable à l'exception des banques
italiennes ya un risque sur les banques
italiennes parce qu'il ya de la
spéculation et à l'elysée les
investisseurs il ya deux banques
allemandes grèce et les doutes sur la
fiabilité des banques et mais tout un
lieu calme de cailloux si vous avez une
économie aujourd'hui l'italie qui va
entrer en récession ne sait très bien ça
va se passer comme en 2012 c'est à dire
que les banques italiennes vont être
attaqués parce que et mais force est de
constater là où il ya le plus beau
jamais dit ça sur la juste christopher
donc on a su par yona on a des personnes
qui ont de l'argent dans une banque
italienne il vaut mieux qu'il rêve en
tout cas les banques françaises sont
beaucoup plus solides acquis selon me
saljic
les voilà rite aliens en partie à prix
très important des banques françaises
c'est ça